all right
Chris yes Chris uh where you from
originally where'd you grow up um East
LA hiding Park in gites area
alino tell me about your family growing
up Mom and Dad my mom and dad they they
both passed
away um probably about like 3 years ago
in
August when you were a kid what what was
your family like um my family I really
don't remember my mom my mom left me and
my four sisters
to uh marry some guy in prison that used
to molest my sister my oldest sister and
uh she she she left your dad she left me
and my sister my dad and mom they were
never married they were already
separated so she left you guys so she
left us to go marry some other guy who
was molesting you that was molesting my
older sister wow she knew that my mom
knew that but she didn't believe my
sister just like any typical any other
story you hear about like the mom just
takes it as as being jealous of the
daughter like trying to steal the
attention and it's not even the
case
um me getting me being 8 years old
getting beat by a grown man like if I
was a grown
man and
uh pretty shocking it's pretty uh
traumatizing I
guess
um when I when I was reminder I had a
babysitter named Jennifer and me being
young I'm not knowing the whole Dynamics
between male and female I just know
we're different at the time how old were
you I was probably about like seven six
seven and
[Music]
um every time I know would take me to my
baby sisters when 30 dancing would come
on like she used to she used to jack me
off I didn't know what she was doing I
just knew it felt good
and then once I got older I
realized like what the she played
me because now I knew what the Dynamics
were a little bit more she was just a
fat chick that couldn't get no play
so she got the whatever place she could
from
me and she was already in college at the
time if I I was like damn if I would
have known that I would have charged her
like you sick
you
know yeah that played a big part of my
my my uh childood it happened for a
while for like three or four years
person I was staying with at the time
didn't know probably still won't know
unless they see
[Music]
this so you were how old when your mom
left um I was about like 8
and like I said I'm the middle child so
I had two sisters older than me and two
sisters younger than me um my sister who
raised you guys excuse me who raised you
guys um family members here and there
and then it got to the point where where
I ended up going to juvenile hall end up
getting arrested and going about life
that way my sisters they all turned out
good they're married they have
kids
um
me I'm still out here
struggling like as far as relationship
wise with my sisters and family I don't
have one you're kind of on your own I've
been on my own especially since last
year in a matter of two months I lost my
little brother my dad my stepmom my
sister my nana and my
grandma oh and my daughter's mom in a
matter of two and a half months
it's been a rough it's been a rough year
for you it's been a rough couple years
from
me you know so
like right now I'm at that point in life
where like I either give it my all and
and come up on top or just get lost
downtown I ain't going to get losted
downtown when you were a kid you joined
gangs
um yeah so to speak I see the giant
tattoo on your head so yeah so to speak
yeah you regret that um n life is too
short to have
regrets like mistakes like there's
mistakes that I made
that that I know
uh I shouldn't have done but regrets no
you done uh prison time I've done prison
time I've done prison time I started my
prison career when I was a little bit
older I didn't get my first prison term
till I was
24 did two two more terms after
that um so about
it and where do you stay now where do
you um it it's off and on right now
especially since I'm between work I'm
usually always working it's just like
right now since I got late um not laid
off but since they terminated my
employment um I'm seeking other
employment but it's kind of hard when
you got nowhere to go staying in the
tent and worried about like oh when I
get when I get back is my stuff going to
be there who's going to be there is
anything even going to be there you're
living in a tent now I from time to time
yes I live in a tent I'll go stay at a
body's house I'll go stay you know
pretty much wherever I can and drugs are
part of your life um drugs have played a
big part of my life a big part of my
life as far as now me my
consumption I don't even get high on it
no more so what's the point well you're
addicted to it though so you um you need
it I'm addicted to Lifestyle I guess and
drugs is just something that comes with
it you either get
you either get get bite with it or you
you
don't I mean cuz sometimes it's a lot
cheaper to get high than it is to feed
yourself drugs are always there drugs
are there they'll give it to you for
free food food you got to pay for
especially with everything going up in
California $4 for a 2 lit
soda
250 a pack of cigarettes when I remember
when I started smoking now they're like
12 16 bucks that's
ridiculous
um my dad my dad my aunts my uncles
they're all heroin addicts um that was
one thing I never got um hooked on thank
God what is your drug Christ uh my drug
choice for the longest was crystal
meth what are you using today um today
all I do smoke wax
marijuana um depends what I have to do
like if I have to go to work the next
day and if I had no
sleep of course I'm going to get high to
stay
awake you
know then you have kids
um from that I know of I have my
daughter
Sky um she's about 17 should be
um am I in her life the way I should be
no am I a good parent
no is it the drugs that kind of kind of
kept you from being a parent it's my
lifestyle that kept me from being a
parent like trying to keep her from
if she doesn't see me then she won't see
the
lifestyle what is it about this
lifestyle that's appealing to you it's
not that it's appealing it's just
that
it's you have to
adapt it's all about adapting to your
environment
to not become a product of it that's for
sure because if I was a product ofer I
probably would have been gone a long
time ago
um
females I mean can't live with them
can't live without
them you know one thing I can say about
my mom though like even though she did
what she
did
uh if it wasn't for
her I probably would have got my heart
broken a long time ago if she never
would have show me how cold heart a
female could be
yeah so that's one thing I have to thank
for I
guess if you had your life to live all
over again what would you have done
[Music]
differently what would I have done
differently U I would have probably went
about the whole part of getting high
differently like not get
high cuz like to the point where you get
high and you're not even high you feel
normal it's when you're not high you
feel Weir in out of
place
yeah but then it all depends on the on
the
person you know like me it depends on
the person and what they how they feel
towards the way people think about
them like me I care less what people
think about me good thoughts or bad
thoughts as long as I'm been thought of
when people stop thinking about me
that's when I have a
problem got to figure a way how to get
back on the talk
list so to
speak do you have
friends um I have friends yes I have
friends do they know about my current
situation and like know do my sisters
know the extent of my situation no
why it's not that it's none of their
business it's just
that they have their own obligations and
priorities to take care of and I'm not
going to be the one to add more to their
plate
you I'll lie I'll tell them I'm working
when I'm not doing good I'm you
know I just got my new pad looking been
working hard and you know it's a big ass
lie but I rather lied on my friends not
my
family
yeah but uh I think out of all the
deaths I experienced
my my Nana was the
hardest she was like the backbone to the
family
that anybody else's
um everybody has that one family member
that their opinion means everything to
him you were close to her
yeah little short Irish Dutch lady I us
smoke weed with her every
day but what do you think she'd say if
she saw you today and knew you were
going
through probably kick me in the ass and
say what the
the only woman that put puts fear
into me
myana I mean what what what physical
harm can she possibly caus me none it's
just
Nana like if she wanted to sit there and
beat my ass guess what Nana's going to
beat my ass and you'll take it cuz she
felt like I had coming and I'll take it
why cuz that's Nana
Chris what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
um it's pray
self
self-interest whether it's your
self-interest or their self-interest
regardless what anybody does in life
with whether they admit it or not is out
of
self-interest you're doing something
you're getting something
because there's something that you want
something that you
need so you try to fulfill
it so M will be
self-interest I'll take more I'll
emphasize more on my self-interest and
worry more about
Mead everyone else around
me
like I try to help help despite my
situation I think I help out a lot of
people and
uh my
pride if I wasn't so prideful it
probably would have be so much of a
struggle for me but I am that's just me
why don't
know and dealing with like situ
sitations like whatever situation
before my dealing with them is not
dealing with them it's way easier to
forget at least for me it
is I'll forget
quick not because I want to just cuz
it's just like a defense mechanism I
guess just a little wall that I put
up
yeah
relationship wise I
suck when it comes to
like taking care of
like my significant other on my
females I
[Music]
mean me loving females I love them I
love them
all but as far as me
[Music]
being able to
uh I don't know I'm lost right
now able to take care of them and treat
them like they take care of them and
treat them the way the way they act
treat them
accordingly the reason being not not
everybody deserves to be treated the
same you
know so I get guess I value I value each
person
different you know based on
what self interest what they could do
for me what I could do for them it's all
it is you think everything is a
transaction everything's a
transaction
life everything everything in life is a
transaction even love love everything
transaction and uh that might be your
problem right there that that is my
problem right there I either love too
much or not
enough or I just don't express it that's
what it
is I don't know how is that
fear yeah fear of I think so not getting
your what you want or fear of getting
hurt all that yeah the
unknown
yeah
to
too late
actually go along with it just to find
out it was a
lie like n you ain't going to make me
look dumb you've had your heart broken
before
yeah
yeah I'm must Sucker For
Love join the club I'm not stupid though
I'll play the part if he's going to give
me like some information I need or like
going to get me to the point where like
I'mma find out some yeah I'll play
dumb yeah go ahead do you do you I make
it seem like I don't know play the part
that I don't
know I
know so I don't
argue you know when someone's lying you
feel it you don't have to know you feel
it
pretty good when it comes to reading
people and
uh don't matter I let you think you fool
me whatever it is what it
is all right Chris thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you wish you
lots of luck out here thank you thank
you
man